my grandmother was born in a gulag and
one of the things people don't know is
once you're released from these camps
you would be you would not be allowed to
live within like 100 miles of any big
city so you'd have to live in some kind
of remote town and they all ended up
settling in these remote towns in the
middle of Siberia and the only people
that lived there were the former
prisoners of the camps a few of the
local native tribes of which there were
many and the guards from the very same
camps that the prisoners came to came
from and they would live in the same
building and what she told me is when
Stalin died right and he was exposed as
having committed all these terrible
atrocities and so on there was a Spate
of suicides in this town because these
guards they all killed themselves
because they genuinely believed they
were doing the right thing when they
were beating these people and torturing
these people that's when I really
learned from early days to get people to
do something terrible but think they're
good you need ideology